let's cross live now to al jazeera's
bernard smith
he joins us live now from paris uh
bernard just give us a sense of the
timeline how did this
unroll this attack that we're learning
about
happening in the city of nice
more details coming in at the moment
hala but it happened
now at about nine o'clock or just before
nine o'clock
local time that's just uh over two hours
ago
and we understand mainly from what the
mayor of nice is saying christiane
estrozi uh he says that it seems the
attackers got into the church
and attacked people in the church we now
know at least
three people have been killed one of the
victims a woman
the mayor says or was beheaded
and the mayor says that it seems that
one of those who was killed
uh was the church warden uh more details
still coming through
the attacker was quickly reasonably
quickly after
after these attacks was detained by the
police it seems he was shot
and injured he's alive he's being
treated
uh in hospital for his injuries and the
mayor christiane estrozi he says that
the attacker kept shouting
aloe akbar even during whilst he was
being detained
uh by the police so that's the latest
details we have at the moment
and also we're told uh that president
emmanuel macron
is heading down to nice hala
um bernard just give us a sense of how
the
the situation is because this is not uh
the first attack that france has seen in
recent days
is it not this does follow that attack
um in the north of the country where a
teacher
was beheaded and that led to a
significant number of uh protesters or
not
yes this attack follows the murder of
the teacher samuel petty he was
uh killed as he walked home from school
in a paris
suburb and it's understood that mr petty
was targeted because he'd given
a class on secularism to students at his
school he was a widely regarded and
respected
teacher and during in this class on
secularism
uh teaching children about the right to
free speech he'd shown
cartoons of the prophet muhammed
cartoons that many
muslims find offensive this angered
muslim parents it sparked a lot of anger
on social media
this got through to this 18 year old
chechen who was a permanent resident
here in france and he traveled some 50
kilometers
from where he lived in the days that
followed the
outrage uh the the complaints over
samuel petty's class and he murdered
samuel petty
beheaded him on the street as he walked
home from school that
of course a very shocking and brutal
murder shocked france
um where teachers are sort of
highly regarded and and respected in
many ways
it shocked france and it came off the
back of
the pro the president of france to
explaining how he
wanted to crack down if you will on what
he
saw as extreme islamic conservatism he'd
already been talking about this
and in the wake of the murder of samuel
petty there was a broader crackdown
on there were some arrests on people
who'd been on terror
watch lists in france uh a mosque in the
paris suburbs was closed for six months
because the imam at the mosque
um had put on facebook on social media
this video of a parent complaining about
samuel petty
and the consequence of that particularly
for example the closure of the mosque
was that
of course the vast majority of muslims
in france
are uh are not involved in any way i'm
not interested in any at all in this
sort of extremist activity
and but there were complaints that
everybody was being
uh blamed for the behavior of one
uh one individual and when this mosque
was closed there are a thousand people
that go to that mosque and they're
saying why are we all being punished
because somebody here uh published a
video so that's
the tension that has been created over
uh
uh in the last weeks well it's certainly
and that's just
in the the last week bernard but this
does seem to be a recurring theme in
fact it has been for many years now
in france we have seen these tensions uh
between uh extremists and then that
brings
the focus onto the muslim community
on the whole and this stretches back of
course to those attacks
in the bataclan on charlie hebdo
just tell us more about this inherent
tension that we have between
france and its uh muslim uh population
well as i say the the vast i'm not sure
the vast majority
of france's popular muslim population
uh would would all feel a tension with
the state but the
the problem that france the challenge
that france has had
is that at a government level it holds
very
dear its uh principles of secularism
that divides
the church from the state and this was
introduced
uh to get rid of the the influence of
the catholic
uh church at the beginning of the last
century and
this is why france introduced this
division of
church and state in more recent
years the challenge france has had like
other european countries
is to integrate into its society
an immigrant population and france's
immigrant population is mainly muslim
coming from former french
colonies and everybody who goes to a
french school
is taught about the values of
republicans republican
republicanism excuse me and and
secularism
and the french model of lacite is that
you
are expected to accept
the french system no questions this is
how it is in france and you are expected
to
to accept that way of living slightly
different from the
more multicultural approach that you
might have in in the united kingdom for
example so the strain has always been
in this way france imposes
its secularism secularism and how
some corners of france francis muslim
community feel
under fire because they don't
uh because of the the the religion they
follow
okay uh bernard we're going to stay with
this uh for just a moment just for any
viewers who are
joining us here on al jazeera quick
reminder of that breaking news coming
out of
nice in the south of france prosecutors
french prosecutors are saying that a
terror investigation has been
opened into this nice attack the mayor
has said that the the person suspected
of carrying out that knife attack
is currently in hospital and we
understand
that three people have been
killed in that knife attack in the city
of nice bernard smith
is in paris for us he's keeping
across all of the detail for us
bernards you mentioned earlier that the
french president's
emmanuel macron will be heading down
to nice uh this is certainly a terrible
time
for france because not only are they
dealing with
the coronavirus pandemic but now we have
this
um what appears to be what the
authorities are investigating
as a terrorist incident there
what can we expect to see from the
government in the coming few hours
bernard
well we've had a minute's silence in the
french
national assembly earlier today it was
meeting
as it happens to discuss the new covid
lockdown that begins essentially
tomorrow in france on
begins on friday in in france so already
uh the nation preparing itself for that
as a second wave
hits france as it's hitting the rest of
europe and it's hitting it
strongly and there's a lot of people in
hospital increasing numbers of hospital
admissions forcing
the french president to go make an
address to the nation last night
explaining why this second not a second
lockdown
slightly modified from the version in
spring was being put into place
um so already there was that issue there
have been in the last couple of weeks
tensions between france and other muslim
population muslim majority countries
particularly with turkey now
um and other countries calling for a
boycott of french
products and french companies because of
emmanuel macron's crackdown on
uh elements of france's muslim society
following the murder of samuel petty so
those tensions were
were there already tensions at an
international
level as i say with some muslim majority
countries in france itself
it was i would say after the murder of
samuel petty there was more shock
and anger than tension um
but now with what's happened in nice
this morning
um people i can imagine there will be
increased tension
that having said that of course because
of kovid
most people will have it will be having
to stay home anyway
so most of the country confined to their
homes only essential travel for shopping
and exercise
and if you have to go to work you're
allowed outside your home
okay bernard stay with us for just a
moment
you mentioned there that minute silence
uh
being called uh in the national assembly
well the the president
of the uh the national assembly has
addressed
members of parliament calling on them to
observe a minute of silence for the
victims and for
their families